I recently read something that you said
about how this project in a unique way
bonded with Jessica Beale in a world
where I think we can be competitive with
each other I think it's so special that
you can be a person who supports both
yeah I was very happy that she she
reached out in that way and
um and yeah there's no need to have
competition stories that are interesting
deserve to be told in every way you're
going to tell it's going to be different
it's impossible for it to be the same I
read that you said she kind of set you
at ease I think it was more just kind of
like a it was like oh great this is this
is nice that we are both acknowledging
this thing because we were filming
simultaneously it wasn't like her show
came out we all watched it yeah and then
or their show not her show but their
show parallel yeah so it was kind of
just kind of like a roll of the dice of
you know what was gonna show first and
yeah and she she doesn't
she didn't want to hide from the idea
that there would be comparisons I guess
yeah but we don't need to compare we can
oh gosh when you read your kids a story
and they're interested in the story they
never say oh my God never read that
story to me again or I don't want to
hear it they say I'd like to hear you
read it and I want to hear you read it
and I want to hear you read it yeah and
I think that that's such a wonderful way
we are just storytellers and and and
we're we're shining a light on this
particular story and I think it's just a
wonderful opportunity
um for viewers to get to experience
the story more than once if they choose
to do so well that was a surprise to us
we were already two months into filming
when that show went into production so
we had the underlying rights we thought
we were as safe as one can be but it's
public domain material and you know that
was a big shock to all of us that there
was another show being made when we were
already filming but
you know there's nothing you can do
about it
I say she was murdered with an ax
what is it about this wild True Crime
Story that you said I must be a part of
it I must play this role it's so odd and
strange and um there's a lot of details
that seem like someone made it up but
they didn't and I think through what
David wrote in his scripts and through
what Leslie also wanted to explore is
trying to
um
share the story in a way that doesn't
cause any any real judgment on any
um on any one person even though
obviously there is one other woman who's
standing in one other woman who's not we
are telling events that are absurd and
sometimes funny
um that lead that all of these chain
this chain of event leads chain of
events leads to this one horrible
tragedy did you kill your wife no
I did have an affair with Candy
Montgomery Jesse we're sitting here with
your TV wife and your TV mistress what
was it like working with both of
them and going toe-to-toe in a lot of
those scenes
embarrassment of riches you know they're
both so talented
seriously it was it was so I mean there
was a moment that I just remembered
where we were in the uh
in the camera test like in the Como
motel and it was the first time all of
us were in costume similar setup I did
feel a little you know well knowing what
what you what you're about to get into
yeah
um but no the they were obviously
incredibly
talented at what they do and
the whole cast I mean the crew was a
collection of some very very
talented people yeah that made it a lot
of fun Lily my goodness we get to see
you rock a bump and we get to see you
give birth on camera in this role how
much of your motherly instincts in real
life kick in when you're presented with
a role like this oh gosh well I was
pregnant I was pregnant through the
shooting of the series oh so that's
that's really you it is and sometimes
it's part of it sometimes it's not
it the my belly was always there oh yeah
exaggerated sometimes it was reduced it
was exaggerated and some in the moments
that it wasn't there it's not my belly
that you're looking at okay there we go
thank you for clarifying so I have
something always there yes I always I
had I had two heartbeats for the whole
for the whole show
um and it was it was quite amazing
because she is is pregnant in the show
gives birth in the show and then at the
time of her death believed she was
pregnant
um so there were all sorts of of
very poignant uh overlaps that were
happening there but they also um they
did this incredible thing that I didn't
know was possible to do because I've
worked pregnant quite a lot now and it's
always you know there's different ways
of sometimes you get to use it sometimes
you're hiding it sometimes
um but in this case we had a not a body
double but a but a belly double really
just my abdomen not my arms and so
um when you are seeing me
without it it's it's all of me except
for my midriff oh my gosh how special
one day your child will hopefully watch
this and see that probably never no I
don't know that I'm never allowed to
watch well maybe maybe 90 years yes
yes but that's always a ways away I
would love to have you and Pat over
I think one of the things I loved most
about this project was that although the
subject matter was very dark and very
serious you do find really unique ways
of infusing a little bit of light a
little bit of of humor and Elizabeth
what a joy to see you singing and even a
little dancing in this role yeah did you
have fun bringing a little bit of light
to such a dark character I didn't think
of it as bringing light to something
dark I I thought of it as
um these these interesting characters
being placed in absurd circumstances
that lent itself to humor and my
on-camera husband Patrick Fugate really
chewed up the scenery with making us
laugh all the time with the choices he's
made but it wasn't because we were
trying we weren't trying to like make
jokes or there's no like haha element
actually when the characters are trying
to make jokes you're kind of
uncomfortable
um but it's really their situations and
the pauses and the relationships that
are creating these awkward moments
that's creating humor
um and I deeply enjoy those kinds of
scenes I deeply enjoy watching you sing
Abba I didn't know how much I loved
Apple
until we were shooting those scenes I
hated disco I love disco now wow yeah
conversion it was a real conversion I
mean I liked Mamma Mia when I was a
little girl and like saw it on tour
um but then I stuffed that joyful part
of Myself Away
foreign